Hey everybody it's peacemaker star peacemaker
i made this explicit trailer for you
it's going to blow your mind all right kids
and that's how i defeated the world's most
dangerous villains with only
my two fists my desert eagle
and two rocket launchers eat peace mother
any questions have you met wonder woman
she did spend an entire party if me from
across the room sick dude i said effin
and a right time to rock yeah you don't understand
what we're up against we need every hand on deck
is that an eagle it's easy a sidekick oh my what's
wrong with your bird such a good handsome boy
dude we're saving the world it's
everything we've ever wanted oh dude
tell me what you know i'll tell you
how do you like that i like it i like it a
lot i don't give a what give it all you got
hey don't worry i'm not giving this guy anything
uh maybe you could just give him a little
hey sweet cheeks can you take my order
real quick seriously didn't chit chat
cheeks it's continent sweet cheeks
is your butt no it's not it is
it's like calling somebody i don't
know sugar tits totally inappropriate
jets are way too big to be sugar tits sugar
sets are like smaller perkier tips like
yours uh technically i think you may have sugar
tits too but somehow that also feels inappropriate
Happy new year everyone this is gonna be my
peacemaker trailer video for the new dc series
based on the suicide squad movie this is meant to
be a spin-off for john cena's character and take
place after the events of the suicide squad movie
the episodes are going to start in a couple weeks
so i'll explain how that's going to work be sure
to subscribe to get them all this is meant to
be like dc's first version of their own marvel
disney plus series where you have movie actors
doing tv series on hbo hbo max and one of the
other cool details james gunn just revealed is
that they actually filmed post credit scenes legit
post credit scenes for each of the episodes just
because he wanted to do something extra special
for all the comic book fans out there that would
be expecting something like that that's actually
been one of my criticisms of some of the marvel
disney plus series is that sometimes we'll get
post credit scenes but in the case of say like
the hawkeye series you get like a really weird
post-credits scene but was more like the marvel
people trolling you with the post-credits scene
but this trailer gives you a little more of the
actual plot of the peacemaker series they still
haven't revealed the actual main mission that
they're going on like what this dangerous mission
that only peacemaker can do is you only see them
recruiting him because the job is so bad it's
something that they can't even use the suicide
squad for if you could believe it the only thing
james gunn has said about the plot that gives any
hints about what it is they're going after during
the series is that there's a sci-fi aspect to the
story as in something else from space or some tech
based world ending threat that's super shady that
the government is probably totally connected to on
the dl there's a scene later in the trailer where
you see this giant swarm of lights in the sky that
look like they could either be drones or some tech
based villain threat or something that somebody
else is manipulating that might have something
to do with that quote-unquote sci-fi story that
james gunn is talking about with the villain love
the way they start the beginning of this trailer
too where he's low-key corrupting a classroom of
children notice the little girl here that has
the flash t-shirt on they asked him about the
justice league characters like have you met the
justice league he jokes about wonder woman giving
him bedroom eyes across the room at some party
that they were at one of the other funny things
about his character is that he is 100 serious when
he's saying all these things like as ridiculous
as he is he completely believes everything that
he's saying but you get the vibe from the kids
that they also kind of think that he's lame like
what this sucks where's the real justice league
the funny thing about that though is that henry
cavill superman actually did go eat lunch with the
shazamly at the end of the first shazam movie but
that's mostly because billy batson's shazam is so
powerful you probably recognize the actor sitting
in the background here yelling at peacemaker they
had another funny clip with him at peacemakers
hospital when they're talking about aquaman
you're kind of bulky to be a superhero aren't
you both superheroes have a gymnast body they're
ready to go i'm ready to go what superhero are you
peacemaker get out of here you're a fan there's
no superhero called peacemaker famous not that
famous aquaman he's famous no man so expect a lot
of references to the suicide squad movie to the
justice league characters like batman wonder woman
superman the other characters like flash aquaman
even cyborg but don't be surprised if you also see
a lot of other comic book references and jokes to
moments in other movies too like marvel references
like they have that guardians of the galaxy slow
walk montage scene later with the actual pet bald
eagle walking with them james gunn most of you
remember director of the guardians of the galaxy
movies in the marvel universe in fact while i'm
making this trailer video james gunn is in the
middle of making guardians of the galaxy 3. don't
worry i'll do separate videos about that obviously
they're going to be showing up during thor love
and thunder but just do not be surprised if
you see all kinds of comic book easter eggs and
references to marvel movies dc movies everything
in this zoom and enhanced on the blackboard
behind them you see the word of the day is
moistly for some strange reason and there's a
bunch of bees and honeycomb decorations above him
anytime i see honeycomb or bees in the dc
universe i always think of hive so maybe this
is low-key foreshadowing for hive in the series
maybe they have something to do with the plot
one of the other main villains you do see him
fighting in all the trailer footage is judo master
in keeping with the suicide squad movie theme of
using c d list characters you've probably never
heard of super weird characters super ridiculous
obscure people i'll give you one guess as to what
his ability is but the other reason why they're
using him in particular is because he's also from
the old school charlton comics group of characters
where john cena's peacemaker character came from
back in the day my guess is that judo master
is either like a mid boss who's working for the
actual main villain or he's just like a really big
side quest that peacemaker encounters during the
series there are eight episodes total so there
will be more dc villains that they'll face and
obviously there's some secret main villain that
we don't know about yet but like i said in all
my suicide squad movie videos usually the actual
main villain in suicide squad stories and that's
kind of what this is it's a suicide squad story
the main villain usually winds up being either
amanda waller the us military or the us government
themselves in some way the rocket launchers that
he talks about are his two arms like he's calling
his arms the rocket launchers as he literally
picks up and throws a warhead at these villains
like this group of workers who are secretly
villains in the background you can see them later
in the trailer jumping around as if they're either
aliens or they have superpowers themselves or
they're hocked up on some kind of super soldier
serum something weird is going on with them that's
giving them these abilities the desert eagle that
he mentions is his shield from the comics it's a
little bit different from the comic book version
but it has the eagle branding on it because that's
his whole thing he does have a cool takedown but
because his character is just so silly it's sort
of like the walmart version of captain america
using thor's hammer and his shield at the same
time to fight thanos like the whole idea is that
peacemaker thinks that he is like a justice
league level character in his own mind i've
already explained most of his teammates in my
previous peacemaker trailer videos most of them
you'll recognize from amanda waller's argus or
her task force x team in the suicide squad movie
they're using the term task force x so when they
talk about this team here these are all people
who work for amanda waller under task force x they
explained in the suicide squad movie post-credits
scene that they feel like they're being saddled
with this peacemaker mission like a babysitting
mission as a way of her retaliating against the
office for revolting against her when she tried to
kill all the members of the team his new sidekick
is a much more comic book accurate looking version
of vigilante from the comics he's a little bit
sillier the way they're playing him like they're
playing him just as crazy as peacemaker is during
the series they did do a version of the character
on arrow but he was a vastly different version
like each of these versions are slightly different
from the comic book version zoom in enhance here
you can see that the team has either hooked up
peacemaker's helmets with a bunch of upgrades or
he's already got these versions like the helmet
that he grabs here is an x-ray vision helmet so
the other helmets have special abilities added to
them love all the scenes with his pet bald eagle
it's literally named eagerly that's what he calls
it and it looks like it's kind of trained like he
thinks of it like a dog but it's more of like a
cat like the way you would try to train a cat but
it's way harder to get cats to do what you want
them to do oh my god he's he's hugging me he's
hugging me dad grab my phone i don't want to move
so just based on the scenes from the other
trailers it seems like the eagle mostly does
just whatever it wants to do and sometimes it acts
like it's obeying his commands there'll be eight
episodes total the first three episodes are gonna
drop thursday january 13th and then after that
it'll just be one episode per week but if there
was any confusion this is connected to the dc eu
just like the suicide squad movie was in related
news there will be a lot more batman trailers
coming obviously that's taking place on earth
too so the robber pattinson batman movie is
not taking place in the dc eu and even though we
just had all that spider-man no way home craziness
the new morbius movie is actually going to
be dropping in a couple weeks and because
of what happened during spider-man no way
home the morbius movie is now connected to
all that we understand some of the easter
eggs in the trailer a little bit better
i know there's also a lot of questions about
that being connected to the andrew garfield
amazing spider-man universe just because of
all the easter eggs so i'll post a new morbius
trailer video probably tomorrow if i don't do it
later tonight so happy new year everyone happy
2022 there is a lot of really really cool stuff
coming up in the next couple of months so make
sure you enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss any of that everyone click here for my full
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
video and click here to learn about how all
the timelines changed at the end of spider-man no
way home for all the other multiverse characters
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!